hello people i'm jaby kawaii with me is achara
kirk we're gonna watch all of us are dead episode
four today if you want the full length uncut
reaction where you sync up with the time code
that will be over at our patreon page if
you can hit the like button that would be
very much appreciated subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when our next
reaction for all of us are dead is up here
on the channel thanks to the boys at prepper
for helping us edit down these highlights
let's have fun it's a wonderful intro jabby
hi doesn't sound that weird
foreign
actually that's pretty smart keep
livestreaming yes get the proof out
i wish i could read the live chat i know
look how they're super chatty i hope
this guy gets to see some of that money
damn lady so worried about you
no
what is that helicopter doing i i don't know
it wasn't just can't they try
to flag down that helicopter
that's so messed up yeah i was really
hoping her dirty like that yeah
i was hoping she would make it at
least part way through this episode
you guys can pee out the window can't
you yeah take turns you know the guys
can be out of the wood you know
just dangle your your bits outside
the helicopter people didn't
notice them on the roof come on
can't you poop out the window
yeah just to sit on the ledge
this is like the weirdest video game
instructions i've ever heard tutorial
the rescuers come with poop as much as we were
just start crapping right in our pants
and then every time you open the door
you'll get hit with noxious fumes
it's the bathroom episode
by the time they're done with this hour-long
foreign
oh is her mom the one who's at
the hospital with the firefighter
oh maybe yeah we know her mom's got status
it's probably not as easy to fly down a
chopper as you move these off and make it
they are really far away yeah and you
must look really tiny from up there
oh god this [ __ ]
serves you right
got him
please don't tell me he's gonna find his way
to the roof oh you gotta be [ __ ] me here
oh
that is the best place to hide that is the
jeez
when is the safest time to move magic hour
guys calm down you guys have the bathroom
you know how lucky you are right now
get those subs buddy your
watch time must be incredible
he's gonna have no more content
after this nothing's gonna talk
back to getting attacked by zombies
way better i hope this guy makes it
damn it must have like some type of external
charger going now korean phones
are just light years ahead of us
comment below tell me where i should go
no come on dude
the day he was born you're an idiot baby
is
oh god i hope he [ __ ] dies i hate that guy so
much this show's gonna bring him to the very end
oh
good debate
there's anyone who could solve this debate get him
some equipment and a specimen lock him in a lab
don't you want a gun man bam john wicked
well accepting them for what you made them though
oh there you go
go man who do it man you're not
gonna have another chance wow
what a death what a symbolic way to die yeah
savior of the anguished
oh man the whole thing went to [ __ ] out there
it's nice things your legs still work after
being pinned behind a truck i thought this cop
was going to be like a total dick and now i'm like
really counting on you damn man yeah our only hope
it's a beautiful morning
oh my god she better be the one to kill him
wow
come on come on
go you're a beautiful man
hopping now drop down all you guys know
parkour oh you guys got strong arms
i mean she might not be dead but
nah she did
just hulk out and throw them all off
what i don't know maybe she's the special what
no way
oh my god it's still scheduled you'd have
to yeah you'd have to go into his account
oh no she's turning i thought i thought there were
some like yeah that she had some
kind of auntie body or something
oh my god oh she messed it up
dammit
oh man dude whoa man
the [ __ ] you're responsible
for so much i hate you so much
yeah he's really gonna fall through with it
i cannot tell what's happening
no please make it my dude
man don't let this happen
make the floor wet so they slip yeah
you mean bolt cutting isn't as easy
as it looks in every other movie
no no come on oh i really want him to live i know
why are you moving slowly
no
do not night of the living dead him
why is someone charging in it i don't
know they'll just chill out for a minute
oh my god no no
damn you straight up murdered
him now turn him back
no
are you [ __ ] kidding me he landed that what is
he's an expertly trained knife
thrower oh god yeah that [ __ ] egg
the amount of depth he's a second he gets the
second episode already out of four is he about
to die yeah yeah oh no he'll be fine what a pain
and he'll charge that guy is god damn what a d
what a what a massive erect penis yeah that was
a gripping show though i was really into that
holy crap that was really great i was like man
this alley flies by it does it's so intense and
[ __ ] hell and a lot of like i don't understand
how this person's living right now but okay
yeah what's the girl in the prince in the
teacher's office jeez i still can't tell
what's happening to her and the choreographer the
way they staged that with the fire hydrant and the
shots outside of the stairwells that are coming
on that was wonderfully staged yeah um that was
that was intense that was really intense all right
let's uh let's talk about it i'm still waiting for
the point in the show when people are like it's
gets slow and boring yeah i know every time i
feel like we've had that sort of preparation
uh like thrown at us or just put in mind
you know for almost every episode up until this
point and none of them have felt anything less
than like gripping and immediate to me yeah i
don't know is it like those little attention
to details of like when they they're trying
to figure out the bathroom situation because
because well the thing is i'm a pretentious
film snob so i love those things i do too
i'm like yeah i haven't seen a zombie flick where
everyone has to figure out where you watch both
the kids and the adults have to figure out oh
wait what about the bathroom now that we've
been here for a day that's such a realistic
thing i like that i weirdly think that's a
really good detail to include in your story and
uh i i appreciate [ __ ] like that i appreciate
the [ __ ] appreciate piss like that i like i
like the details of of a weird situation like that
because when you're isolated i don't know have
you guys ever tried writing something you guys
if you're writing something a lot of
times especially if you care about like
realism of what characters might have to deal
with i i i that's something that oftentimes like
in a movie you're like we don't have time for
that let's just move along nobody cares a show
why not take some time to to have a little
bit of a awkward discussion about what that is
and yeah you know the bathroom thing
is that's a huge it's very relatable
yeah that's a relatable and especially with the
kids who can be uncomfortable with such a thing
anybody you can be uncomfortable with such a
thing yeah like it's it's a human vulnerability
that we all have to experience and they get most
all cultures or many cultures have like a lot of
you know finicky things around so yeah having
everybody lumped into this room together it
like i don't know to me that's part of the fun
of the science fiction of this is going okay
what is the true scenario of survival and how do
we encompass all the aspects like because there's
that and then they go on talking about like you
know we're gonna run it we don't have any food
or water so you know we're gonna be dehydrated by
tomorrow and we're gonna starve by the next day
yeah they're well-educated kids too so i like
seeing their the intellectual discussions
around it and then them trying to understand what
someone else is really implying or really talking
about i think though those those nuggets are so
vital i think to to making this stand out and
uh even like the this is the most like adult
drama that i think we've gotten of you know
like it seemed like it was pretty equally split
or divided between going to the hospital like
if you siphon it off between uh guinom and the
rest of the kids like being the kids and then
the other storyline being the hospital and
the cop you know so it seemed like there was
a really equally divided story line between uh
kids and adults and what they're dealing with
and uh what is the dad's name we have him did
we do not write his name down here no oh no the
father the creator of yeah or a great zombie virus
lee something or other just call him creator joe's
dad oh no oh that guy okay yeah yeah the creator
the creator of the virus yeah sorry i thought he
was a firefighter dad but yeah the firefighter
that i'm so joe is the firefighter i wrote it
down oh you did wow we have ten characters so
terrible yeah um well okay where to start with
i mean we'll find out what happens with with
these with some of the students like uh oh we
didn't write her name down either we should
have taken the time but the girl who is the
one with the who's been videotaped you know um
that i think one of the most p piece uh biggest
pieces of conversation to derive from here is the
one that is argued between the cop and creator
and watching uh like discussing like
the the differences and how this all
progressed you know and like we've the show covers
so much about the what the the the effect of being
bullied does and what that can ignite and i like
the moral debate of what they had of like how do
how is it up to us to decide when is it okay to
take a life and when's it not okay to take a life
or how this show like like i said i'll
reiterate again for americans who don't
have much familiarity with how you know societal
norms are in like south korea and stuff however
like at least the world that this show presents
is like the the way how with this hierarchy goes
societal systems and whatnot uh systematic systems
i mean and how that all plays out like when he's
when the when the creator is talking about um you
know they everyone had a role to play everyone was
complicit to a certain extent just based off of
societal norms that they would not stand up for
such a thing that it's just normal let's justify
the situation let's minimize the situation let's
downplay everything and the fact that a lot of
people are kind of privy to a lot of the bullying
that goes on in a lot of the the inhumane ways
to treat people so by proxy or just association
just by being witness and not doing something they
have a hand implant they play a certain hand in it
and so i like like where they establish where the
creator dad was coming from especially when it's
your own son who is the one who has to suffer
the consequences of what is being passed along as
normal and just because it's normal doesn't mean
it's okay and then of course on the cops end of
things being like okay you said a few things right
but that doesn't mean it's like you got to kind of
uh you know give punishment based off of the way
the crime is done you can't just automatically
jump to murdering and what this show is also
doing is bringing it back to a more uh archaic
biblical time in a way like there's so much
talk about humanity too and you know bringing
humans back to their more animalistic roots to
how we were years ago and i think that's kind of
why like the bathroom thing is is a fascinating
thing to me because you know we just finished
kingdom and there was a section in kingdom where
you know like back when the show kingdom takes
place another korean zombie show that's a much
more historical time period where i don't think
this whole thing about like where do we [ __
] and piss is gonna be as much of a discussion
because like there's they're they're they are
qualities luxuries yeah they don't have toilets
that flusher or you know [ __ ] like that that we
rely on uh for comfortable hygiene when going to
the bathroom so i so i like that this is like
stripping us back to the bare bone minimums
and then like the way he was comparing it with
um like uh should uh about like he was making
like animalistic comparisons oh yeah they're
seeing eye dog should all should all dogs give
up their natural instinct to run and bark should
all people give up their natural instincts too
yes for civility's sake yeah so if anything and
he does die in in this like that jesus-like pose
that they didn't like slow motion it down but it
did seem like a really symbolic way for him to die
as like the creator yeah who dies they completely
devoured every inch yeah yeah so i think that this
is a i think it's fascinating the way they do it
and while they take their time out to have these
more philosophical discussions about live
society morals humanity whatnot it's also uh
just a gripping intense series too i i think
of the the zombie [ __ ] is really gripping to
to to watch and there's some deaths in here
that really kind of that bugged me a lot like
um uh chung sun's uh mom being killed at the very
top of this that sucked so much he's so rooting
for her the way some of these people die is just
so uh it adds to the realism of it and sometimes
it is like it's it can be frustrating it's stark
in matter of fact in a way it's funny because
there are certain things where like you know the
the main guy yeah uh chung sun like he he escaped
a few scrapes in in more of a kind of traditional
narrative sense but yeah i i like that they are
willing to really dial in that bleakness when it
comes to like there are so many characters who get
set up with these motivations where you're like
well they can't die or we have to see some kind of
dramatic resolution and you know part of i think
the point of some of those things is that yeah
especially i mean in life already and then in an
advanced accelerated situation like this it's not
gonna work out like that and so i'm fascinated
to see what they're gonna do with the girl who uh
you know who's undergone the with
the tape who's undergone this intense
sort of assault and bullying because it seems as
though they're hinting at some kind of thing where
like she's getting taken over very slowly i can't
tell if they're going full zombie with her or not
but even that is like you want to see her get some
kind of retribution and it appears as though she
probably won't and that's kind of you know
that's one of those sad twists of the knife
that you're like yeah you know in the real
world she probably wouldn't get some kind of
big uh emotionally satisfying resolution
out of this and i liked even that debate of
them on the roof and and you know the guy with
her and the positions that they're both thrust
into because that you know is obviously under the
microscope now of you know complicity and assault
and you know seeing the two of them both
emotionally work that out and then come
to how their wills to live and why are affected by
this and these two people who are so beaten down
and her with somewhat of you could argue with even
more reason you know to be feeling this way than
him you know her being the one to be like no i'm
going i need to do something at least you know
um yeah i i've seen a couple of those comments
too people saying you know like i you know
like there's a lot of cool intense stuff but then
it'll just like take a break to explain the point
um and i i maybe we haven't come to those moments
yet but i feel like you know there have been
moments in this episode that made me think of
those comments but i didn't really share that
opinion either that same thing about slowing down
or isolating the point i feel like a lot of the
debates they're having are natural debates
to be having in the settings that they're
put in and being that this is such
real time being that we're only
on the second day like we just got through the
first night you know and uh yeah i feel like this
show is a great example of how to have your
cake and eat it too with a zombie story because
by the end of this i would imagine you know it's
like you have all these different characters
between the adults and the kids who are all
standing in for different kind of issues or
conflicts that exist within society and then we're
seeing the kind of the overarching umbrella is how
like the the need to adhere to a certain
societal protocol keeps us from getting to
the actual solution to things or to some kind of
actual healing or some kind of actual progress
um so like it's i'm fascinated by how they're
using the characters and to see where some of them
will end up to understand what the true
point is because there's a lot that does
when you have characters dying in such abrupt and
stark ways some things can feel sort of random
but i don't begrudge at that necessarily
because that's also an aspect of life
you know well i think this the the theme
of this particular episode was about
um the value of life and what is the value
that we place on life that seemed to be what
it all even even down to the girl when
she was brought with the the question of
why why kill yourself when that that video is
already going to be out there yeah like is is
it worth it what can you really escape
people already see it and that seemed to
be like the biggest stem for when you look at
like everything that you were watching here of
how and then even with the firefighter and the
politician lady um how they were talking about he
wants to go save his daughter but she was saying
like we have to we can't just save those that are
most precious to us we have to we have the most we
have to save the most we can and so again it goes
back to value in life and it's a really i think
it's a really interesting debate that they have
per episode with the through line of of um
inhumane treatment and that this how the
zombie virus in a lot of ways is representative
of who we are underneath at all yeah which i've
heard brought up in in zombie properties before
that this is merely an amplification of the human
nature uh at the same time though it is it's
done in a more uh visceral way where they keep
the action alive still where some stuff doesn't
like you sometimes gets brought into question with
its rules like the guy who was trapped behind
the car i'm like this guy would have been dead
yeah yeah how's this guy's like hey how's he
moving is he walking yeah and how did he not
just get devoured on the other side yeah yeah yeah
unless they mistook it but i do think that girl
i don't know i think i wonder if that was just
some mislead of her like slightly twitching yeah
because they did start chewing on her and
then then they left her yeah they they just
they markedly stopped yeah and we're like uh we're
gonna go someplace maybe she's dead on the inside
and it's some kind of metaphorical magic i don't
know but yeah like that that of all the threads
that's the one where i'm like she's the special
somehow maybe they're gonna do something where
like the bullied kids all have some special gene
if you've been victimized to the extreme yeah you
are immune to the virus which is not true i mean
we've seen some people could not because i mean
the first kid would never have turned yeah
yeah it would never have worked but yeah this
is a fascinating this is really well done and
even with the politic even with the the woman
like i i thought they did nicely coming out of
the previous episode to make even the people
in the office feel a little more nuan like they
didn't just cling to that one beat of like it's
she's the councilwoman what are you doing
she's the most important person why aren't you
catering to her at all like they kind of left
and progressed a little beyond like they're still
aspects of you know those protocol like the
principles like you know you're expelled
uh for doing this which is like i don't know you
know those don't apply anymore uh so like those
aspects still persist in certain pockets but i
feel like the way they're advancing even those
things with those characters who initially present
themselves is ah you're going to be frustrating
you know they're good at wearing those edges
down and uh now all that i'm gonna wait and
see is if they're able to do that to uh to uh
what's her name not young because uh you know
i imagine in the next episode chung's son has
to come across her and miss park at some point
now they're out they're all split up and
stuff maybe they can help him get rid of
guinom or something it seems like the worst
people tend to survive this situation yeah
or hey i mean maybe maybe guinom will
run into the girl and she'll just eat it
maybe they're holding her transformation until the
just the right moment uh that's kind of what i'm
hoping for but now there's something a little
too thematic about what happened there yeah
all right we'll see anyway it's good i
i'm really enjoying it and i i'm yet to
be bored nah the only time i thought the
rhythm was off was the first episode yeah
yeah i can't wait to watch the next one each time
we finish what like it's funny because yeah they
are so substantial and i've said this each time
they're each like a movie but yeah they fly by
yeah and i think the way they captured the zombie
action is choreographed so well too oh yeah just
like so compo like it's so visceral and mean and
the actors are so committed to that but also it's
so composed and so thought out like it's it's
mightily impressive what they're able to do here
oh god i don't know what's going on with the
helicopters i don't either i mean i i i just
like i guess they don't have that many resources
and uh yeah are they just rescuing people slowly
i know that you never see them drop down like
unless i got a flare don't go down there yeah yeah
i mean because yeah we see that that big line of
them from the kids perspective and i'm like yeah
what's are they just hovering there what's going
on or are they just tending to again yeah like
people in the city positions of government
or something maybe i mean helicopter can
drop down on a school roof can't they yeah
it doesn't seem like it would be that hard
they just need a flare that's all they need they
got to go to the they've got our influence for god
too yeah oh yeah that's right i hope he makes it
i like that a lot i love seeing his little live
stream comments we got a couple translations of
those in the subtitles yeah i don't know it also
seems like it does this thing about like a lot of
this seems to be some weird commentary on status
too yeah status and the ways that it pollutes our
ability to just see a situation for what it is
and do the right thing yeah you know it's even
like the influencer thing while funny also has
a commentary to it yeah of like like and subscribe
yeah like like it's funny but i also think there's
some deeper thing to it because um what was
the point i just said [ __ ] so i thought
i forgot what i said uh it having this
thing about his statuses yeah and authority
oh yeah it's like this is this is oh yeah it
comes back to like stripping people down to
we've created these more like
we've we assign as humans as we
age on in this planet we assign what is right
and wrong like there are things that we consider
wrong now that a hundred years ago would have
been totally cool you know and this is just keep
stripping that back even more and then people
still try to use status in a position to of
applying what's who's more important when like
none of that matters anymore like threatening
your bully character with i'm going to expel
you i'm like that shouldn't matter right now
what do you think what leverage do you think you
have yeah i know that i know in the moment though
but i think that's what this does well is a lot
of the times you can read more into things because
another version of that is that the principal's
just desperate to manipulate the student to
get in the car yeah you know that's mainly
what it what it reads as but there's also
when you look at the other conversations that
sort of circulate around this series i think that
also factors in even right down to
the creator guy like he was he felt
pushed into this position to try to come up with
something because no one was standing up for the
the the plight of whatever his what his son was
dealing with at the time so yeah let it all burn
let it all burn yeah i mean i felt i felt
for him i was like this isn't the solution
but also i got you yeah yeah they did a
good job i got you man all right guys well
keep a lookout for our next reaction uh
thanks for being here and hey let's do a p
lance door you're the easiest one to shout out
for this why because we have a character in this
episode who is a badass firefighter helped save
the day oh yeah and objectively speaking there
is only one firefighter at our patreon page
and that's you so guess what when the zombie
apocalypse rolls around we're gonna need an asian
firefighter on our side yes and you fit both of
those descriptors man lance i'm happy to have
you on our patreon page and speaking of status
we'd be the most important people you'd have to
protect yes your kid's not gonna make it in the
apocalypse all right there's no point in even
trying what are you gonna try to repopulate no
don't forget the kid all right forget the wife
they're holding you back in life we're going to
be the ones you're going to need to protect so
lance i appreciate your loyalty because loyalty
is important especially in the apocalypse
fidelity that counts for something man
i use that word right yeah faith fidelity yeah
as we're talking about yeah fidelity
to us to to you know your bros
well you know i mean we uh we went
through the whole thing about like
you know you can't have that fidelity for
like you know wife and kid because they're
just gonna weigh you down in the apartment
oh i don't believe in that [ __ ] no okay
you could always replace those